why hello there good people
i'm dave rubin this is the ruben report
direct message for today
june 1st 2021 happy pride month
to those of you in the lgbtqi
lmnop community you're gay big god damn
deal nobody cares let's move on
as always guys don't forget to click
that subscribe
button tap that notification bell and
maybe you will
see our videos and as many of you know
last week we started
clipping the direct messages so usually
i cover about three stories a day here
five days a week
we are now clipping those so in case you
can't tune in live
at 11 a.m pacific you will be able to
see the shorter videos
throughout the day today we will be
doing uh three
stories i think we mixed it up nicely
first off we're going to cover some
memorial day tweets or non-tweets by
some of our politicians and it seems to
be getting increasingly
more difficult for democrats to say not
only anything about
nice about america but about the
veterans
and the soldiers who we've lost over the
years who actually defend our freedom
who are far more braver
than any of our politicians or me or
most of us and they deserve all the
credit and i hope you all had a great
memorial day weekend and
for those of you that have lost family
in wars i hope you took some time to
be appreciative of of their service and
for everybody it doesn't matter if you
lost family particularly
uh everybody i just i'm feeling very
i'm feeling very patriotic today i
really am i'm just feeling like we got
something to fight for and i think more
and more people are realizing that
the more memorial days and labor days
and fourth of july is that pass
it's like maybe we're starting to wake
up and realize that these days are
set up to remind us something like
independence day we're supposed to
remember something memorial day the
people we lost
maybe we should be thinking about these
people so we're going to cover some some
tweets and non-tweets
by some of our favorite politicians uh
then we've got an update on that middle
east war there's some really
bizarre things that if you watch the
mainstream media you're not going to see
victory parades
in gaza i thought they were being
genocided
and violence here in the united states
while people of gaza are actually going
out to the beaches
we're going to juxtapose some things for
you uh there's your word of the day
and finally a new study has come out
that is showing that
liberal women have far more mental
health problems than conservative women
i had a feeling about this and we're
gonna dive in
to the numbers that i'm sure are racist
and white supremacists and all that
stuff
uh before we do any of that though i
want to talk to you guys about about
black rifle coffee
you know black rifle coffee is a
veteran-owned coffee company serving
premium coffee to people
who love america veteran ceo and founder
evan hafer spent over seven years on the
ground overseas with u.s special forces
and as a cia contractor black rifle
coffee is continually committed to
supporting veteran law enforcement
and first responder causes isn't that
refreshing
in our country and overseas courageous
frontline workers risk their lives every
day to protect ours
inspired by their hard work and
dedication to protecting their
communities black rifle coffee makes it
their mission to give back to those who
serve
however they can throughout may they
rallied behind law enforcement officers
firefighters
first responders active duty military
and other frontline workers
by spotlighting local heroes through
community nominations donating coffee to
keep the front lines caffeinated and
giving back to organizations
that support our nation's heroes they
import their high quality coffee beans
from all over the world and roast five
days a week at their facilities in
manchester tennessee and salt lake city
utah
the team at black rifle coffee is
continually researching and
experimenting with new roasting methods
and coffee origins
you can purchase at blackriflecoffee.com
ruben and use code ruben at checkout for
20
off your first purchase including your
coffee club order that's
blackriflecoffee.com
slash reuben and now back to me i'm
drinking black rifle coffee
right now
delicious all right so uh the big
controversy
over the weekend was uh that kamala
harris who is our vp
uh a woman who is incapable of going
down to the border she doesn't want to
go down there although
supposedly she's in charge of the border
but refuses to go down there she has an
evil witch-like cackle of a laugh and
uh was polling at zero percent in her
own party primary when she
uh stepped away from the nomination
process and then somehow was
installed as vice president but great
gal great gal uh
she tweeted on friday well we've got the
tweet right here with a picture of
herself
smiling as any good democrat does they
make it about themselves
and not why we're having a long weekend
she just said
enjoy the long weekend no mention of
memorial day no mention of
you know our soldiers and brothers who
have lost their lives defending our
freedoms none of that kind of stuff
and that actually did cause uh i would
say
somewhat of a warranted outrage we're
all outraged all the time but this one
seemed kind of legit like how about just
have a nice memorial day weekend or
i'm appreciative of being an american or
something like that but she couldn't
choke it out
and then and then the twitter people
started coming in and then the new york
post
covered what happened next vice
president kamala harris posted a more
fitting tribute to america's military
sunday
a day after drawing online heat for
telling her
her fellow countrymen to enjoy the long
weekend and then we've got the actual
quote from harris once she was sort of
guilted into saying something nice
she said throughout our history our
service men and women have risked
everything to defend our freedoms and
our country
as we prepare to honor them on memorial
day we remember their service
and their sacrifice so this got me
thinking actually because when i saw the
tweet you guys know i don't tweet on
weekends so i didn't tweet on saturday
sunday or monday but a few things
occasionally come across my phone when
i'm you know just from notifications and
things
uh so i started thinking well the the
kamala harris thing is not that
surprising to me i i always find
and you can go back and do your due
diligence on this i always find that on
memorial day on labor day on 4th of july
even on thanksgiving
that the progressives the all the
political leadership
and the pundits they all really struggle
to choke out
anything sort of positive about america
or they couch it in but we've done
horrible things like they just
can't sort of outwardly do anything
positive towards america but don't take
my word for it just
search any of their twitter feeds with
those days in mind and you and you'll
see
that that's pretty consistent so
interestingly aoc
and ilhan omar from the hamas caucus of
the democratic party
they did not say anything about memorial
day on their personal pages they didn't
say anything
uh elizabeth warren did say something
that was sort of perfectly fine nothing
nothing too uh intense and then i just
thought i'd give you some good ones
just some basic ones so we randomly just
picked a couple republicans guys who
i've
chatted with on the show who i think are
decent people who kind of like america
here's rand paul
he said on memorial day we honor the
brave men and women who made the
ultimate sacrifice for our country
always remember the cost of war and
cherish their
lives pretty good how about that ron
desantis guy run in florida
like a boss this solemn day we remember
the sacrifice and lives lost by the
great men and women of our armed
forces who fought to secure liberty and
freedom for all
this memorial day i asked floridians to
pause at 3 p.m
for a moment of silence to honor our
fallen heroes
god i love that guy ted cruz this
memorial day heidi and i honor and
remember the soldiers who paid the
ultimate sacrifice for our freedoms
thank you to all of america's heroes and
their families for your service see it's
not that hard
to say nice things about america it's
not that hard to say nice things about
the people who made
the ultimate sacrifice so that guys like
me can babble about this stuff on
youtube and so that the rest of us can
go about living our lives
and then of course there was that donald
trump fella you may remember him
uh he's sort of like beetlejuice been
banned to the netherworld unless you say
his name three times and you
spin around backwards or something uh he
released a statement but i thought i'd
read it because he's not on twitter so
uh and you're not going to see it on
mainstream media and i thought it was
pretty good so
why not read it he said we remember the
fallen heroes who took their last
breaths in defense of our nation
our families our citizens and our sacred
freedoms the depth of their devotion
the steel of their resolve and the
purity of their patriotism
has no equal in human history on distant
battlefields
in far off oceans and high in the skies
above they face down our enemies and
gave their lives so that america would
prevail
they made the supreme sacrifice so that
our people can live
safely and our nation can thrive in
peace it is because of their gallantry
that we can together as one people
continue
our pursuit of america's glorious
destiny
we owe all that we are and everything we
ever hope to be to these unrivaled
heroes their memory and their legacy is
immortal
our loyalty to them and their families
is eternal and everlasting
america's warriors are the single
greatest force for justice peace liberty
and security
among all the nations ever to exist on
earth god bless our fallen soldiers
sailors
coast guardsmen airmen and marines so i
thought that was worth mentioning
because
uh yeah it's kind of kind of right and
it's kind of true
and i'd be curious to know and we're uh
we're discussing this in the uh
in the locals community
reubenreport.locals.com like are you
guys feeling a little more patriotic did
yesterday
feel more important to you as it feels
like this thing
this american project is sort of
slipping away
and the hysteria of of the woke left and
this ever
growing government and six trillion
dollar bills and let's bankrupt the
whole thing
like is it starting to feel more
important to you to defend america
it is feeling more important to me i
would also contrast that and compare
that
with what i've been saying about
holidays lately that that
religious holidays have started feeling
more important to me because in a time
as the secular world just completely
crumbles uh
i'm finding value in these eternal
stories this is obviously something
jordan peterson has talked about
for many years and actually uh i'm going
to be interviewing somebody
i'm going to i'm going to hold off on
mentioning who uh that we'll post next
week that's going to be very much about
that that i think
you're going to enjoy anyway let's move
on to the second story because there
were a couple interesting things
that came out this weekend that don't
quite fit the corporate press
narrative and i think it's important to
show so first off
hamas and these are the terrorists
basically that run the gaza strip
okay they run this tiny little piece of
land that's just a sliver
of the entirety of israel basically that
is
and i talk about this all the time that
israel is basically the size of new
jersey this is just a tiny little strip
that before 1967 was part of egypt it
was never part of a place
known as palestine that had a prime
minister or president or anything of
that nature
well they had a victory parade this
weekend and i thought we'd show you this
victory parade because you're not going
to see this on mainstream media
but it's quite curious because i thought
israel was bombing children
and there was a genocide and ethnic
cleansing and all that stuff
seemed odd that you would run a victory
parade but here it is you may want to
lower your volume a little bit
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i would imagine they were singing about
peace and coexistence and that sort of
thing
um if you don't think that that's odd if
if they were
you know ethnically cleansed and all of
the horrible things that everyone said
israel was doing a week ago and now
they're having victory parades
also really reminds me of auschwitz
doesn't it that's the other thing they
always say it's like
the concentration camps yeah yeah you
ever see pictures from the concentration
camps pretty sure they weren't
driving around with missiles and
everybody looked sort of fat and healthy
and
all the rest of it but then
if you don't think that's odd enough
that that doesn't sort of fit the
narrative this video came out
this is gaza's packed beaches this
[Music]
weekend
[Music]
well there seems to be a narrative
buster for you right genocide open air
prison
it's like auschwitz they're just
enjoying the day
on the beach which shows you that what's
happening on the ground is very
different
than what you're seeing in the news and
the reason i showed you all this was
because then
this weekend in brooklyn you know the
these black lives matter and antifa
rioters protesters whatever you want to
call them they've now
had this intersectional bond in hell
with the palestinian activists and here
in new york city at the brooklyn bridge
we've got some pictures we'll throw to
you
they had massive protests where they
basically shut down
the brooklyn bridge so you've got the
people actually in gaza
on the beach trying to go about living
their lives you've got the
hamas terrorists a self-described i mean
they're a self-described terrorist group
they want to wipe out all the jews right
not just those mean israelis all the
jews
they're having a victory parade they've
got people on the beaches but here
our activist which is exactly what
rashida talib wanted she wanted to
combine
these you know quote-unquote oppressions
so now you've got in some ways
our activists here in new york city at
the brooklyn bridge
in many ways being more radical than
the people on the ground in gaza and
there is a reason for that that goes
beyond just what our awful
progressive politicians are saying the
new york times this is i mean this is
just so fascinating you really got to
pay attention to this
the new york times had an opinion piece
a couple days ago
called the myth of coexistence in israel
and we're going to show you the map here
so this is a
map that they showed in this piece that
ran in the new york times and i've
covered this a couple of times on the
show
but that map is complete fabrication
msnbc used to show that map and they had
to retract it
what you're seeing there on the left
when they say all of that is palestine
the implication is that there was a
country
known as palestine okay there wasn't you
guys all know this there was
the british mandate of palestine for
many years and then before that there
was the ottoman empire and in the place
of palestine there were no people
known as palestinians there were arabs
that lived there and there were
druze and jews not druids from uh
spaceballs they're probably some of them
there too
um so that's the first map that you're
looking at then the second map is
basically what you're seeing there
is the 1947 partition plan that's what
they could have had they could have had
two states these the jews
said yes we'll take it the arabs said no
then launched a war and lost
then the third map they show here is
complete fabrication because the
green in the third map here on the right
what the big chunk on the right that's
jordan that was jordan then
and on the left as i said before the
gaza strip that was part
of egypt then on the fourth map here
they're trying to imply that now
palestine is smaller that's starting in
1994 when the israelis for the first
time gave
palestinian people self-identified
palestinian people
an area to control of their own so the
israelis are the first one they gave it
to him i know this history gets all
annoying and by the way bill maher you
know i've been a little critical of bill
maher
lately because it's like he's a lefty
but he's not completely insane and i
would say he's mostly he's good on free
speech but
he actually basically repeated a
complete show that i
did about two weeks ago uh laying out
the history of the area and i
will give credit where it was due
whether his guys watched my show and
decided to do it or not
he actually did a nice defense of israel
and it was nice to hear from a liberal
perspective because it's been so bad but
in any event so they
the new york times runs a piece called
the myth
of coexistence in israel showing the map
that is a complete fabrication
and then finally because people pushed
back they had to admit it was basically
a piece of art so this is from honest
reporting
but arguably far worse than the piece
itself was the times choice of a graphic
one that spreads
the tendacious lie that between 1948 and
1967
palestine shrunk and this disappearance
continues up until the present day
and here's the amazing part when pressed
the times deputy
opinion editor patrick healey submitted
that the graphic
should not be taken literally this image
was used
as art a top and opinion ss essay
and we felt that the art image helped
illustrate her arguments in a statement
yes a fictitious art did illustrate the
written word
in the fictitious piece the new york
times is
genuinely evil it is it is a place of
evil it is not a place of journalism
and if you think that that's excusable
that they can
put up a map to correlate with an
opinion piece and then
after and nobody reads the retractions
that's why i thought this was important
to do nobody reads the retractions
afterwards they say oh
the picture we put up that everyone sees
the picture and they see the headline
very few people read the
the articles or the opinion pieces it
was just art
it didn't have anything to do with an
actual map or factualness
oh these people are just ridiculous and
that's a perfect segue to the third
story because this
links to this new study that liberal
women in particular are going completely
bananas
we've got a quote here from evie
magazine there was a new study and this
study
which examined white liberals moderates
and conservatives both male and female
found that conservatives were far less
likely to be diagnosed
with mental health issues than those who
identified
as either liberal so we've got this
image up and this is
pew research okay these people are
reputable as far as i'm concerned
uh what you're seeing all the way on the
left there the 56.3 that's the the high
blue bar
that's white liberal women 56.3
of white liberal women have had a doctor
or other healthcare
provider told them that they have a
mental health condition
now you go to the right over there and
the 27.3
see white conservatives so this is white
liberals white moderates and white
conservatives
only 27.3 of white conservatives
have had this happen to them and what's
interesting so basically in effect
double so basically double
white women who are liberal are
suffering from some sort of mental
condition that conservatives are not
and i think you can directly link that
to the previous story
that if you only read liberal media you
don't know what is true anymore and you
can take any position depending on what
trump said
or you find out three weeks later that
every story that they tell you is a lie
you can't talk about
uh kovid leaking from a lab then you can
you're told brett kavanaugh's a racist
then you're told he's not jesse smallett
was lynched then he wasn't lynched the
covington kids were evil white
supremacists then it turns out that they
weren't
trump tried to pressure the attorney
general in georgia to flip the election
results then it that turns out to be
false
these people are are inundating
themselves with nonsensical information
that doesn't comport with the real world
in front of them and then they're
starting to go crazy because then they
find out real information but they're so
tied into a sort of political identity
that they can't actually accept what's
real and by the way i don't think
and i made this argument in my book i
don't think you can disconnect that
from having something to do with belief
i it's such a strange place
for me to be arguing from but i really
do believe that that
conservatives generally speaking and not
all conservatives are believers
obviously
but believing in something it doesn't
mean we all have to believe in the exact
same
god it doesn't mean we all have to have
the exact same traditions
but believing in something helps keep
people sane in the storm it keeps
the ship afloat when you're in an
endless
wade of [ __ ] and that's what we're
in right now so liberals
are all kind of going nuts the and i
mean that and in this case i mean that
when i say liberals and not lefties
because there really
aren't any liberals left despite being
the guy that wrote the book defending
liberalism right
um they're all sort of going nuts
because
things are obviously far worse
politically
and i would say culturally now than
under trump like that's just
obvious if you care about any sort of
liberal principle
that's just deeply obvious and yet
people are now
not saying anything right the liberals
really are doing nothing in the face of
this because they don't want to be
called scary conservatives
and what i find consistently is that
conservatives are open they're decent
they're willing to talk
all that stuff that you all well know um
so it does not surprise me that over
half of white
liberal women the women these people who
self-flagellate
right these people who there was this
incredible video that went around of
some school
zoom thing where a white teacher tells
people
she will no longer teach spanish because
she as a white woman shouldn't be
teaching spanish
it's it's becoming a mental disorder
woke-ism is a mental disorder and it has
infected a huge amount of people and if
you are liberal if you are a true
liberal and you're watching this show
i hate to tell you but you're a scary
conservative now
but they'll be nice they're actually
nice it's gonna be okay
it's gonna be all right uh guys i got a
busy week i'm going to austin for
a live event with the heritage
foundation in a couple days
uh so there will be no live show on
thursday however we are doing
our weekly q a a little bit early we're
going to be doing that tomorrow you can
submit
questions at reubenreport.locals.com
part one of my interview with kirk
cameron you guys remember kirk cameron
who was mike seaver on growing pains
which was one of the seminal sitcoms
when i was growing up because i was
basically
the same age as mike seiver and it
turned out we thought
that growing pains in my town in science
and long island we thought
that growing pains took place in
sciasset kirk actually enlightened me it
took place one town over
but it just very much that show just
reminded me of my childhood
and i've gotten to know kirk over the
last little while and he's just got an
interesting story related to being a
child star
finding what he really believes in
fighting for america i mean he's a true
patriot and and just a really decent guy
so we had a really fun interview part
one of that is up on youtube right now
the full episode of course
is up already completely ad-free at
reubenreport.locals.com
i've got a couple things to do i hope
you're feeling rested and recharged from
the weekend
let's take that feeling maybe because i
think you might have it too
of a little pride in the country a
little patriotism a little honoring of
the people
who were before us and let's see if we
can continue fixing this thing that is
my goal this week
join me on that crazy radical right wing
adventure everybody
see you tomorrow
you